good morning
and thank you for joining this panel on
civil liberties in a crisis
i'm silky carlo the director of civil
liberties campaign group big brother
watch
and i'm honored to be joined this
morning by fabulous barrister and human
rights expert kirsty brimello
guardian journalist damian gale and the
former minister
now leading rebellion against the
excesses of government's rule by decree
steve baker
over the past six months britain has
experienced the greatest loss of liberty
in a generation the whole nation was put
under house arrest and freedom of
movement was suspended and still is for
millions of people
elections have been suspended protests
have been criminalized
and we're now faced with a new dawn of
biosecurity
yet as the population pays the price in
liberty
thousands of lives lives have been lost
in underserved care homes
whilst emergency care easements have
left the most vulnerable people adrift
and key workers are still struggling to
get the ppe and tests that they need
the balance between citizens and the
state has been capsized
and even the balance between parliament
and the government
a government elected on a mandate to
give back control
to parliament to make laws has been
toppled
emergency powers are always sold on the
premise of being strictly necessary and
temporary
yet the government chose not to use the
civil contingencies act
but rather to impose more permanent
legislation through the coronavirus act
and a sprawling network of hundreds of
statutory instruments governing
every aspect of our lives from how many
people can sit in our gardens
to the decibels of noise that a bar or
restaurant can play
the question is how can we and how will
we restore the balance
and prevent permanent damage to liberty
democracy
and the rule of law in britain
i'm going to ask each of our guests to
give two minutes of their initial
reflections on this question and we'll
start with kirsty
thank you very much silky well looking
at the title civil liberties in crisis
reminded me of thomas hobbs the 17th
century philosopher
when he considered a world of an
all-powerful government
and the fundamental of course of
authoritarian rulers
is that power is centralized and the
theory behind it is that without
absolute governance there will be
acute civil disorder and of course
hobbes's theory of government was based
on a theory of society which in itself
is based on a theory of
human nature and what we're seeing with
the laws and the amendments to the laws
the regulations is uh perhaps a small
group of
people's perception of how people will
behave
unless they're governed by uh
criminalization
uh by punishment uh by law
now hobbes of course concluded
the very famous quote that probably a
lot of people in this audience will know
is that a world without laws means that
the life of man would be solitary
poor nasty brutish and short
but of course what we've seen is that
laws themselves aren't a solution
and in fact they can be part of the
problem if they are not
just if they are not clear and if they
are not accessible
in substance and application and over
the last six months uh
not only have we seen people confused
but we've seen
the ministers responsible for the laws
that have been brought into force
confused and the amount of times i've
literally been shouting at news programs
where ministers have been wrongly
stating what the new law in power is
and so how are the public meant to
regulate themselves if those
uh actually including the secretary of
state for health
and then laterally the uh the uh
secretary of state
um uh priti patel cannot get it right
and explain what the laws are and
uh sadly it isn't a joke because this is
having a real impact upon people's lives
now very briefly there are
uh the health protection coronavirus
england
regulations there's similar uh
regulations for the other three nations
they are the regulations that prohibit
freedom of movement
aspects of our family life there's
secondary legislation
and they come under the public health
act 1984
in order for them to be virus i.e for
them themselves to be lawful
they need to fall within the purpose of
the public health act which is
preventing
protecting against controlling or
providing
a public health response to the
incidence or spread of infection or
contamination
if they are outside that such as being
used in a public order sort of way
then they are ultra virus and
they are liable then to be quashed
uh i have about 10 seconds remaining so
i'm going to just
push on through uh with the points i
want to make which are these
the latest amendments uh which came in
uh
at the weekend uh one minute after
midnight
uh a sunday night stroke monday morning
show that we have now moved to
regulations which are ultra virus or
potentially ultra virus
for example we now have offenses of
fining an employee
if the employee does not notify their
employer
within a particular time frame that
they are self-isolating how is that
helping the spread of
prevent the spread of the virus that's
the question we also have a new offense
here
uh of for somebody who knowingly gives
false information about somebody else
and obviously that is a an example of
where
the informing on your neighbor has been
shown to backfire but again
how is that within the purpose of the
public health act we've also seen a
massive increase in fines
i remember when the the regulations came
into force the 26th of march 220
we were looking at 60 pound fines uh now
we're starting at
a thousand pounds and up to ten thousand
coronavirus is struck in different ways
as well as the devastation it's reaped
in taking people's lives
it's cleared a road for the government
to emasculate the rule of law
and this places us on a far more
dangerous road than the one to barnard
castle
thank you so much kirsty uh next uh
damian can you give your reflections
yes so um i cover policing and protest
for the guardian
um over the past two weekends i've
watched as the police used violence to
break up political protests on the basis
that they were breaking the coronavirus
regulations
um on the most recent on on saturday
afternoon just passed
the met said it decided to break up this
protest which involved
probably tens of thousands of people on
the basis that trafalgar square was so
full that people could no longer adhere
to social distancing rules
the commander said this avoided the
organizers risk assessment
meaning it was no longer no longer
covered by an exemption
that's supposed to allow for political
protests
the police then moved in and and they
use their battens to break up their
crowds that break up the crowds in
and i'm quoting in in the interests of
public safety
but it didn't end up being very safe for
the people who got cracked in the head
by the police
um whatever you think about the aims of
the protests and
frankly some of the people who are
involved in organizing them
and joining them have got some quite
batshit views
these people should have had a right to
protest there was no threatening
behavior there was no damage to property
and the role of the police ought to have
been to facilitate that right not to
deny it
and if some of those genuinely believe
that the royal family
are lizards from space or that donald
trump is waging a secret war to rescue
children locked up in tunnels underneath
the major capitals of the world
there were a lot of others who went
along because they had a sense that
something wasn't right with the powers
that the state has assumed to deal with
the pandemic
i think even beyond those who join the
protests
there's a growing sense there's a
growing constituency of people who have
a sense that the government response has
become excessive
um set against them there's there is
still a huge proportion of people who
believe
that given this seriousness of the
pandemic no government intervention can
be too
too draconian and this is where i think
we have a problem
while there are people who've developed
legitimate lines of questioning over the
pandemic
there is not much of a sensible popular
movement to channel and articulate their
concerns
so people are connecting on facebook and
they're sharing conspiracy theories
and they're finding their concerns
articulated by people like david ike
or piers corbin who variously believe
that the virus doesn't exist
or that it's activated by face masks
or that injections of mistletoe can cure
cancer
or all kinds of other kind of weird
weird um weird ideas about public health
so the question is where do we go from
here and i think part of the problem is
that we need to try and
develop a a mass kind of sensible
mass movement of people who can
articulate these concerns about the
increasing totalitarian nature of the
way the government is behaving
um and can channel some of this sense
that people have
that something is not right about what's
going on at the moment
um i know that there are organizations
like yours silky big brother watch who
have been doing work to try
and raise awareness of the lack of
oversight
of the laws that have been passed and
some of the
some of the worst consequences of them
but we need to try and find a way to cut
through to these people
who um on the ground generally genuinely
feel
that there's something weird about not
being able to have
more than six people in their home and
yet being able to go down to the pub
and can see these contradictions and um
want to try and want to try and find
some way
to to go back to the freedoms that we
had before
thank you and i very much hope big
brother watch can be that mass movement
that
um is so needed at the moment and
finally
uh steve baker good morning everybody
and first a big thank you to the
spectator for making this possible a
huge thank you to big brother watch for
everything you've done to support us in
parliament
and thanks for the t-shirt as well and i
should just acknowledge liberty and say
thanks to liberty as well
so we all know that the road to hell is
paved with good intentions and yet here
we stand wandering down the road to hell
looking around us and all together too
few people are
raising concerns about what's happening
with parliamentary democracy and the
rule of law so i'm really thrilled that
we're here
i'm definitely on the right panel having
listened to the other panelists
i said um something on ridge which felt
very risky at the time i said
uh how do people think that liberty dies
well it dies like this and
i meant that sincerely and it seems
actually to have landed
uh quite well uh people do realize that
parliamentary scrutiny of the law
uh retrospective scrutiny and so on is
uh in great trouble
and people realize that the rule of law
is in great trouble
that's a point i'll perhaps come back to
in a moment what i wanted to say was
something about the forces which i think
are at work because only by
understanding
what the forces are at work can we do
something about them so
i'm going to talk about the people i
know best first politicians what is it
that politicians want well they want
power we all know that the crucial thing
about
politicians and power is they trust
themselves to wield it
politicians trust themselves to will
power and i have to say haven't been a
minister
you know officials trust themselves to
wield power too they're quite
comfortable with having power through
regulations
uh because of course they're all they
will know one another jolly good chaps
and
you know they know their motivations and
so forth but much as i trust the good
faith of
members of the cabinet who i'm now
privileged to say that i know personally
it's not one of the principles of a free
society that we should have the rule of
those in authority
and be uh allow our lives and the rules
uh
on which our lives depend to be set by
individuals and their discretion but
that is the direction in which i'm
afraid we have been pushed by necessity
and
people will know the old quote about it
being the plea for every infringement of
human liberty so politicians and
officials trust themselves to wield
power but we don't want to rely on their
good faith so who's going to hold them
to account well first of all let's say
something about this parliament i don't
want to be too partisan
it is of course conference season and
that means during the course of this
debacle
the other party is perhaps a bit
distracted but the poor liberal
democrats are in such a state
going through their conference well
where are they they're absent well
i can understand why they're absent but
i would say to anybody watching this who
supports the liberal democrats please do
encourage them
to get stuck in on these issues because
if the liberal democrats don't stand for
liberty and the rule of law
well i think the question uh starts to
answer itself the the labour party
of course the labour party do believe in
state power they do believe in
collective action to further the safety
and security of
of people and collectively but i think
that's leaving them at something of a
disadvantage a point perhaps i'll come
back to
talk about have time to talk about
rights for a moment
um the snp have a great conception of
their entitlements their rights but only
in relation to independence it seems to
me and i would really love for the snp
to rise to the challenge of scrutinizing
uh the rule of law in this government
now that then turns to my own party so
something's going on in my own party
with a majority of 80
it's conventionally thought that most
politics has shifted to the cabinet
table
because of course once the cabinet's
decided usually you would find
that the cabinet would get its way so
what's just happened in the last week or
so is
a rebellion has grown from 40 i tabled
the motion with 40 names on it very
deliberately
and uh now uh you know i i would say the
reports in the press of about 80 is
are accurate as far as i'm concerned so
that's an absolutely huge rebellion we
can't keep
holding the government to account like
this my party won't which simply won't
do it so we need the opposition to come
back and that's why i've touched on it
but for the moment here we are so just
say a word about my own party most of my
colleagues in parliament are pragmatists
some are neo-conservatives that means
they're very comfortable with the use of
power songs it's them using it
if i would to a bridge and then there's
people like me classical liberals very
skeptical of power
but somehow we've just formed a big
coalition of members of parliament from
all
three of those groups to say actually
this has gone too far i'm afraid i
haven't got the time in front of me
silky so i'm going to go on until you
tell me to stop i do think that we've
got a problem with a prevailing
mainstream
if i may i'll quote karl popper because
i was just rummaging on my website
i see now more clearly than ever before
that even our greatest
troubles spring from something that is
as admirable and sound as it is
dangerous from our impatience to better
the law of our fellows
and of course he was writing that in the
context of the chaos the first half of
the 20th century
i think we need to be really careful
right now in our consideration of rights
that we don't con confuse freedoms from
and freedoms too that is we don't con
confuse those rights on which our
freedom rests
with entitlements to things which
perhaps are not universal and reciprocal
because i think one of the factors at
work here
is that people who ordinarily would
stand up for civil liberties
are actually a bit confounded because
the state is acting for the betterment
of the public
and that is in a sense disarming lawyers
and i'd be really interested in lawyers
feedback on that
it's a nascent thought but i'm quite
concerned
where are the civil liberties lawyers
you would normally expect to hold
government to account where is the
opposition
and i think with that i will probably
pause there's much else i could say but
i really appreciate being here and i
hope we'll
flesh all these issues out thank you so
much
kirsty i'm going to come to you to ask
if you can respond to that and also if
you can just spell out very briefly
uh for for anyone who might not have
thought very much about this issue
exactly what the dangers are of living
in a country that has
emasculated or really abandoned the rule
of law
yeah thank you with it with the query
where where are all the lawyers
um i suppose you you kind of get within
your own
bubble on on that and so i mean i i
brought the first judicial review uh
against
um against the regulations on on the
the prohibition on um the right to
manifest
manifest religion so that was in april
absolutely
it was pretty quick it was only a few it
was actually the last week in uh
in ramadan um but it didn't get much
publicity
so although there was a number of press
who were aware of it
i'm i i think it's i think it's a good
question from my perspective
um from work from where i am at doughty
street
we've we've never been we've never been
busier with with these cases
and also i found that working with
ngos such as big brother watch uh
where we've actually and we also put a
team together
of lawyers when uh to deal with all the
fixed penalty notices
that are occurring so it might be
there's quite a lot going on but we're
just not we're not really publicizing it
i've got a case of a jr for example at
the moment against a fixed penalty
notice
and we actually i think we can take some
credit
with the times newspaper on causing the
cps to review every single one of its
charges that i'm brought
under the chronovirus laws and that was
after
a very strong um public
uh campaign where literally i was
looking at the cases which the times
were alerting me to
and then we worked with big brother
watch where there was clearly something
wrong with the prosecutions
and i was saying yes that one's unlawful
that was unlawful
i didn't even need to go into court it
was being published in the times and
then the next day they were setting
aside the convictions
uh so that that was that was completely
novel um but at a technical point you
you you always need more and
and i also would support what you say
about you you need the other political
parties
and what i haven't understood myself is
why
for six months there have been laws
which have been issued by decree which
comes on to the second part of your
question silky that laws go through
parliament they're scrutinized by
parliament now it's not perfect but
there's checks and balances in there and
there's questions that are asked
and it's understandable at the beginning
of the pandemic that you're using
emergency legislation
but it's not understandable six months
in or even in fact
one month in i think and so that but
that
until yesterday there has not been any
murmur
or objection from any political party as
to why we are being governed
by decree and um his legal historians
will know that the
the last time perhaps that happened was
was was back in the time of um
king charles the first um the the law
the law is really important because
if you don't have uh equal distribution
of the law if you don't have legitimacy
legitimacy is a fairness flaw
um if laws become arbitrary they become
disproportionate
then what always happens is the most
vulnerable in society will be the ones
who are the the most impacted um those
in minority groups
we've seen some worrying statistics as
well concerning the issue with fixed
penalty notices i know big brother
watched a lot of work on this
as as liberty and so we're already
seeing that coming through
and if you don't have a robust
uh legal system which is um has got all
the checks and balances within it and
the safeguards within it
again with the regulations from fixed
penalty notices there's no right of
appeal
and you've got on the one hand you've
got the folks review ongoing
why why do we have so many judicial
reviews and then you've got legislation
brought in by the government
which gives you no mechanism to appeal
other than to use a judicial review
um and so there's a lot of issues there
when when when the law is brought in
in this way the other final thing i
would say is
when you have a mash-up of messages from
the government and guidance
and then that's confused with law that
in itself weakens the law itself because
the police have been we've seen it
happen many many times
i've been involved in many cases where
the police have just mixed up guidance
thinking that's the law with the law
itself
and so um that that any confusion
anything on
uh distorting clarity accessibility
uh basically leads to chaos and this has
really confounded the public hasn't it
um damian i was wondering if from
your experience of um covering
some of the backlash to this in
particular the protest you've sensed
a change in in public mood i mean it
certainly seems to me
that back in april to declare yourself
as anti-lockdown
meant one thing but now actually that
probably applies to
a much greater portion of the public
because
we're not in that initial stage of
not understanding the virus of
emergency legislation i think people do
have the sense that they're living in
something
akin to a to a dictatorship maybe strong
but certainly rule by decree without
doubt
what was your perception of of that and
of the
the public mood at the moment i think
that's right i think that there are
people who
are always going to oppose this no
matter what but i do
i did find from a lot of the people who
i spoke to that um
they admitted to me that just like
everyone else when the pandemic first
broke um they were
beautifully staying in their homes when
they were out they were
making a wide berth to avoid people but
um
as they'd seen um things progress and
particularly as they'd seen predictions
um like the the
prediction of the potential death toll
given by neil ferguson
of imperial college that we could have
um i think he said 500 000 deaths in the
uk
um things like that not come to pass and
then obviously
um ferguson's famous um liaisons with
his lover
at the height of lockdown seeing those
hypocrisies from
uh the people who are supposed to be in
charge of
of uh implementing these laws
i think has had a big impact on people
but also seeing that
when this all began back in january we
were watching
um videos and social media from wuhan
and it looked like uh the apocalypse was
basically on its way
and then in italy we saw those famous
photographs of intensive care units
totally overrun with patients
and we saw the huge
mobilization that our government made to
to bring in all of the nightingale
hospitals and
to try and import personal protective
equipment from around the world
and in the case of the nightingale
hospitals at least it seemed that they
they were not needed they never really
admitted any patients and i think people
then
began to become quite skeptical about
what the government was telling them and
then once
uh we all got the all clear and we're
told to leave our homes
and uh told in no uncertain terms to go
back to work
and to put our children back in school
and to eat out to help out and to start
going back to the pub and getting back
on public transport
for that message to then be reversed as
it has been in the past
week or so that has further muddied the
waters for a lot of people
and i think that's possibly part of the
reason why a lot of people have started
to
become skeptical about what the
government is telling them
i mean obviously there's a huge
constituency of people who
never believe what the government tells
them anyway um
sometimes you could say that's with uh
potentially good reason
but um i do feel that the numbers on
these protests have have grown
um from the the first one on the 29th of
august that was that was a big protest
but i think there was slightly more
on the one on saturday
and if you had combined the one on
saturday with the one the week before
um then um you know obviously a lot of
people weren't able to make it to both
then you know i think there's a there's
a really large growing movement against
this
it's a serious movement growing against
it and i think that's
uh reflected somewhat in the newspapers
as well
um steve you made a point about power
and power
trusting uh people in power trusting
themselves
to to wield that power of course boris
johnson is
um the a self-proclaimed
liberal um and yet he's standing
standing over this extraordinary as
kirsty puts it emasculation of the rule
of law
rule by decree let alone a lot of other
things going on in the background with
digital ids facial recognition
um really in many in many senses we're
seeing one of the most draconian
governments that we've seen in a very
long time
do you think this is a fundamental
problem with power itself and something
rotten in the political system
or what what's this what's the um
political solution to this well silky i
i i
there's so much as a practical
politician i want to challenge in what
you've said but i'll answer your
question directly we haven't got time
we haven't got time look i am an
all-round classical liberal in my
outlook moderated by pragmatism that
comes from being a practical politician
but if we live in an age as i think we
do
where the general assumption in the
media and in the minds of the public
very often
the most prevailing assumption seems to
be that the state has omnipotent agency
it can do
anything it's if only ministers were
competent enough
well if that's the assumption and it's
very rare people talk about
partiality and media and so on i can't
remember the last time i was asked why
do you think the government needs to do
that
don't you think that we should leave
room for civil society families and
individuals in that area
this is not a question which gets to ask
that the assumption is always that the
state should do more whatever the
question
that the state should do more and the
only problem that's going wrong is the
incompetence of ministers
and i'm afraid this is not very
realistic um you know i'm not
english liberal for a reason and that's
because i don't think power is the best
way to organize society
so i've long argued and we haven't
possibly got time to go through it here
that we are in the midst of a developing
crisis of political
author political economy since the end
of the second world war
there were the two world wars i believe
were a ideological war of transformation
wars of transformation from
classical liberalism to let's call it
interventionism rather than offend
social democrats but i've done it now um
but
we're in the crisis of this belief that
the state can do everything and it's
really come to a head
in the midst of this coronavirus
pandemic so that is i think the issue if
we can persuade people to be liberal in
all things and that means freedom from
coercion
uh perhaps i'm a very difficult thing
for a politician to approach living with
a bit more virtue
well maybe maybe we'd start to make
progress as a society but i think we
should have to we should challenge the
fundamental assumption
that state power that is coercion of
people
is the answer to all of our difficulties
i firmly believe that it is not
absolutely and unfortunately it seems
that coercion has been used
uh to make up for sometimes what's been
lacking in the state's ability to do
other things such as providing testing
and other kinds of
really management questions rather than
political questions yeah and if i may
because you've provoked me there's been
this assumption that people can be
forced to comply there's that dreadful
spy
m document that you've put out about
people's sense of personal risk needing
to be increased
but if you look at the king's college
research there's an enormous gap it
seems between
between people's intention to comply and
what they actually do
this raises a really dangerous then
question
if the public has something of an
immovable object is the government
really going to keep on
applying ever greater degrees of force
until it's irresistible
this is not where our society should be
headed so i i wonder i mean i've
previously floated that we should move
on to a voluntary basis
that would be a very serious step
because this continues to be a very
dangerous disease
for those vulnerable to it but um you
know i think if we want to be a virtuous
and free society we've got to
re-establish parliamentary democracy in
the rule of law
that raises profound questions for the
basis of these rules
and just for anyone that may not know
exactly what steve was referring to i
think you're referring to um documents
showing
the the government's um strategy to
increase
fear in communications that's right yeah
yeah which a lot of people have have
remarks on and
you know been accused of um just sort of
baseless speculation but that that is
certainly the case that is a strategy
um kirsty and then damian can you just
briefly respond to
um steve's point do you think one way to
protect civil liberties in this crisis
would be to um to manage this through
strict guidance and information and
support rather than
uh the kind of um hard edge of the law
yes i i i would be in favor
of a an accessible
instrument of facts scientific easily
accessible scientific facts not not a
press conference with
scientists flanked by politicians and
press asking questions
and actually many countries i do a lot
of work in colombia and it's it's a
constitutional case actually established
um the right of people to have the facts
on which they can then base their
their decisions and regulate their own
conduct i think that would
so people can understand the purpose um
secondly
uh we need to stop potentially
criminalizing people this destroys
people's lives
finding people at these times of extreme
stress
as well um it is is setting up
um divisions within society it's also we
can't simply blame the police either
uh because they're confused and and
you're always going to get overzealous
officers
uh misapplying um the law um
even if the vast majority are doing
their absolute best and we've seen that
happening
so you need to remove that power which
is within these regulations
put it in guidance i completely agree
with steve
on we are a liberal democracy we are not
again i'm going to refer to some of the
countries in latin america where i work
such as colombia
we are not we are not one of these
states which does
crack down and we are moving towards
crackdown and that is not this sort of
society that
over hundreds of years that we have
fought for those freedoms and
protections
to now be dragged back to it is a
serious pandemic
but they're are different ways of of
approaching it to try
and save people's lives but at the same
time
protecting the core of how we actually
live our lives we shouldn't sacrifice
that which is what unfortunately i think
is happening in the moment
um thank you and and damian can you give
your response to that in just 10 seconds
i'm sorry
sorry yeah i think you know the
government has a lot of work to do to
try and overcome some of the cynicism
that's emerged um i think uh an
impartial
source of evidence would be really
helpful but we have to somehow fight
back against the conspiracy theorists
who have
somehow seized control of the narrative
well um there is certainly a lot to a
lot to go through here and i think
um there are some of the
concerns that people have are extreme um
but extreme concerns are
well-founded at the moment um we're
talking about the emasculation and loss
of the rule of law
we're talking about the greatest
suspension of liberty that we've ever
had
and we're seeing massive massive public
pushback and if we live in a democracy
then
we have to respond to that and we need
our mps to respond to it so tomorrow is
a really big day
with the renewal of the coronavirus act
motion
of course we'll be watching very closely
to see what happens um
and i hope that some of this discussion
plays into um
some of our thinking about how we get
back
where we are and how we get back to some
kind of state of uh normality
so um please follow us all on twitter
we're all there follow big brother watch
thanks again to the spectator for having
us and thank you for joining us
you